but tonight we're going to celebrate a
lot of people have spent a lot of time
over the years trying to get rid of this
mayor and we would say at the top of
that list the Chicago Alderman our
friend Raymond Lopez who joins us
tonight for an after Action Report
congratulations Alderman Lopez uh on
what happened last night I have no idea
what's going to happen next but it's
worth pausing for a moment to say
democracy worked does it not
absolutely Tucker good evening and
before we start let me just say our
hearts and prayers are what an officer
in Chicago tonight that it was shot in
the line of duty in the most dangerous
of American cities right now but
with what happened with yesterday's
election democracy worked and the
Pendulum I believe is starting to swing
in the right direction back to the
middle back towards common sense where
the the outrageous policies of woke
narratives and agendas are coming to an
end and I think that we have one more
chance in Chicago one more hurdle to
reach where we finally put this to rest
where we could have common sense Prevail
across the entire city where the
law-abiding citizens are the ones that
we're fighting for and that where the
city is no longer safe for criminals but
for the good people of the city of
Chicago
hey
the most basic possible standards for
governance like can you walk outside
your house without worrying about
getting shot to death and I think that's
the place to start so do you think you
said there's one more chance is there a
candidate who you think in would uphold
this that standard
yes I think we have a runoff in six
weeks in the city of Chicago because
nobody got the majority of the votes uh
yesterday uh one of which is Paul vallas
the former CPS School uh CEO and a
former budget director for the city of
Chicago he's backed by law enforcement
supports all our First Responders and is
basically billing himself as a problem
solver his opponent is a Cook County
Commissioner Brandon Johnson who is
super left tied with our teachers union
and his claim to fame is being able to
take away the background checks for
renters so that landlords don't know who
they're renting to come on I mean the
end is uh just yesterday would not uh
disavow looting in the city of Chicago
as a means as a justifiable means so I
think we have some pretty clear choices
in Chicago it's just up to the voters to
not fall for the narratives not fall for
the race baiting and gaslighting but to
focus on what we need to do to put our
city back together
so one candidate is for restoring Safe
Streets the other won't disavow looting
so I it seems like a pretty clear choice
Alderman Lopez I hope you'll come back
with an update on that race thank you so
much congratulations
thank you Tucker
in August of 2020 Kyle Rittenhouse shot
three men in self-defense there's no
dispute that it was in self-defense it's
all on video in a jury reached that same
conclusions that's a fact he shot them
in self-defense but self-defense itself
is no longer a defense it's becoming
illegal in this country one of the men
who tried to murder a coward house with
a gun in his hand which is on video is
now suing Kyle Rittenhouse how does that
work what kind of Rittenhouse joins us
to respond straight ahead
plus our second gentleman
the dude who's married to Kamala Harris
who won't kiss him without a mask on has
some thoughts about toxic masculinity
ladies and gentlemen buckle up
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight